Hey, Vsauce. Michael here.
I am at the White House, in America's capital,
Washington, D.C. America makes a lot of
feature films every year -
Hollywood. But they don't make the most
feature films every year. Nigeria makes more.
But the country that makes the most
films every single year is
India. Every two years, the country
of India fills up enough film with unique
feature films
that stretch all the way from this city,
Mumbai, to where I live,
in London. That's double what Hollywood
produces in two years.
That is a lot of movies, but is
real-life a movie? I've discussed the frame
rate of the human eye before but how
does the resolution
of the human eye compare to a camera or screen?
VHS, LaserDisc, DVD,
Blu-ray, IMAX. Numbers like these are
pixel dimensions. When multiplied
they tell us the total number of picture
elements an image is made up of.
A figure often used to describe digital
cameras. It might sound like
more is better, but to be sure numbers
like 1920 by 1080
are not resolutions per se.
More pixels is only part
of the equation. Resolution is about distinguishing
fine details and that depends on a lot of other factors.
For instance, the amount of light, the
size of the sensors,
what the millions of pixels are actually
encoding and
how close the subject is. I mean, up close
Salvador Dali's painting of his wife
looking at the Mediterranean can be
resolved into boxes. But from a far,
well, it's Abraham Lincoln. For crying out
loud, on a small enough screen
from far enough away, low and high,
so-called resolutions on screens, aren't
even resolved differently
from one another by your eye.
How different nearby pixels are from one
another also matters. This is called
spatial resolution.
For instance, if I go out-of-focus
the number of pixels in the video frame
stays the same but you can't resolve as much
detail. Now, with all this in mind we can still
compare human vision to a digital image,
by asking a better question.
Assuming everything else is optimal, how
many pixels would you need to make an
image on a screen large enough to fill
your entire field of view
look like real life, without any
detectable
pixelation? Now we are getting somewhere.
Kind of. The analogy is still crudy
because a camera snaps an entire frame
at once, whereas
our eyes move around. The brain amalgamates
their constant stream of information
into what we call vision -
sight. In fact, the image created by the
eyeball alone during a single glance
would hardly even be acceptable on a
broken TV screen. We think
our eyes create images like this picture
Guy took of me with a camera.
But for one thing, unlike a camera,
you've got some stuff
in the way. For instance, you are always
looking at your own nose, and maybe even
glasses,
if you have them. Luckily, our brains
process those stimuli out because they
don't matter
and they don't change. But thinking those are
the only difference
is a pitfall, literally,
latinly. The fovea gets its name from the Latin for
'pitfall'. The fovea is the pit on your
retina that receives light from the
central two degrees
of your field of view, about the area
covered by both your thumbs
when held at arms length away. Optimal
colour vision and 20/20 acuity are
only possible within that little area.
When it comes to these limitations XKCD[.com]
has a brilliant illustration.
It points out other problems, like blind spots - literal blank spaces
in our vision where the optic nerve meets
up with the retina
and no visual information is received. If you bought
a camera that did this, you would return it.
You can find your own blind spot by closing
your right eye, fixating your left eye
on a point in front of you,
extending your left thumb and then moving it
left-of-center slightly slowly carefully
until
it's not there anymore. Crazy(!)
But, of course,
we don't see the world horribly, like
this, because our eyes are constantly moving,
dragging foveal resolution wherever we need it.
And our brains' complex visual system fills in details,
merges images from both eyes and makes a
lot of gueses. What we actually see
is a processed image.
Not computer-generated imagery, but,
well, meat-generated imagery.
The neon color spreading illusion
is a great way to demonstrate this
difference. There is no
blue circle in this picture. The white here
is the same as the white here. A camera
isn't fooled, a screen isn't fooled, only
you and the fleeting gumbo of
ingredients you call perception
is fooled. Our vision
is not analogous to a camera. But our
reformulated question can still be
answered because human anatomy allows us
to resolve, to differentiate certain
angular distances. Famously, Roger N .Clark
used a figure of 0.59 arcminutes
as the resolution of the human eye to calculate,
based on the size of our total field of
view,
how many of these distinct elements
could fit inside of it.
The result was an approximation of
exactly what we want to know:
how many individual picture elements -
pixels - our vision can appreciate.
His answer? 576 megapixels.
That many pixels, packed
inside a screen large enough to fill
your entire field of view, regardless of proximity,
would be close enough to be undetectable
by the average
human eye. But we should factor in the fovea,
because Clark's calculation assumes
optimal acuity everywhere, it allows the
eye to move around.
But a single glance is more analogous to
a camera snap, and, as it turns out,
only about 7 megapixels,
packed into the two degrees of
optimal acuity the fovea covers during a fixed stare,
are needed to be rendered undetectable.
It's been roughly estimated that the
rest of your field of view would only need about
1 megapixel more information. Now that might
sound low but keep in mind that there
are plenty of modern technologies that
already use pixel densities
better than we can differentiate.
As Bad Astronomer deftly showed,
Apple's Retina Displays truly do
contain pixels at a density
average eyesight can't differentiate from typical
reading distances. But the fact that
there are screen sizes and pixel
densities that can fool the human eye
is not a sign that we see in
any kind of megapixelly way. Human vision just
isn't that digital. I mean, sure, like a
camera sensor we only have a finite
and discrete number of cells in our retina.
But the brain adjusts our initial
sensations into a final perception
that is a wishy-washy top-down processed blob
of experience. It's not made of pixels
and furthermore, unlike a camera, it's not
saved in memory with veracity like a
digital camera file.
Absolutely no evidence has ever been
found for the existence of a truly
photographic memory. And what's even
cooler is that not only do we not
visually resolve the real world, like a movie camera,
we also don't narratively resolve
conflict and drama in our lives
like most movie scripts. The point of
all of this, what I'm getting at,
is an idea. An idea that initially drew me to this question.
We play roles in the movie of life,
but it's a special kind of movie.
Cinematic victories and struggles are often
discrete, resolved, like pixels, with
unbelievably perfect beginnings and endings,
whereas the real world is all about ear resolution.
I like how Jack Angstreich put it in 'Cinemania'.
In a movie, a character can make a
decision and then walk away from the camera
across the street and have the credits
roll, freezing life in a perfect happily ever after.
But in the real world, after you cross
the street,
you have to go home. The world goes on.
Life doesn't appear in any particular pixel resolution
or narrative resolution. Things are
continuous. The world was running before
you came around and it will continue running
after you are gone. Your life is a plot
only in so far as it begins
and ends and occurs in medias res.
Damerish opens illustration for
Charles McGrath's endings
without endings says it perfectly. In life, there rarely is
the end. There is only
the and.
And as always,
thanks for watching.